welcome to firm learning i hope you all
had a great christmas holiday
i for sure spent some great time with my
family
we are now outside taking a little
christmas walk
hope indeed you'll also find some time
to relax and to recharge your batteries
in these difficult times
so today i have a very special video
idea for you
i will talk about how to set goals and
objectives for 2021
and i use a system that also large
companies use to set their goals for the
whole
corporate level and this is a system
that is called
okrs objectives and key results
you might have already heard about it
it's a pretty
common pretty well-known system and
today i'm going to show you
how you can adapt the system simplify it
a little bit but
make it work for your personal life as
well
so welcome to another video here with me
with firm learning my name is heinrich
i'm a former mckinsey consultant and on
my channel i try to help you to become
successful
in the first years of your career but
now without further ado let's
jump into it so see you in a moment so
welcome back home and let's start by
talking about how to set
this up in the right way from an
instagram survey i know that many of you
are not
used yet into this whole process of
structured goal setting for the next
year and if this
is you if you do not have clear goats
for the next year yet
or maybe you have some things in mind
but not really a structured process of
how to put this on paper
i would just encourage you to try it out
try it out this year
and test for yourself whether this makes
a difference for you and of course i
hope that with this video i can provide
you a framework that can work well for
you as well the next question
then always comes is okay how do i do it
how do i write it down and of course
here there isn't you know the one
correct thing that you need to follow
you can do it on pen and paper you can
do it in a note
program like one note or evernote
personally i just like to do it in excel
because it's a tool i often work in
so i'm gonna show you how i write down
my goals in excel so if you do that if
you do write it down in excel or maybe
you also use some other technologies
like this but i would encourage you is
to not just make a new document
then you save somewhere and then very
likely will just forget about it and
never look at it again but rather
included in a document
included as a tab in a spreadsheet that
you naturally open
up on a regular basis so maybe you
already have a spreadsheet that you use
for some other things related to
personal growth
and by this you make sure that you
naturally will open up this document
several times over the upcoming year and
this then always is an opportunity to
look back into the step to look back
into what you wrote down
now at the end of the year to remind you
of what you wanted to achieve
so what is the methodology for goal
setting that i can very much recommend
and really use for myself
this methodology is called objectives
and key results
okrs and maybe you've already heard
about it it got quite popular in the
last years in the corporate world
to my knowledge it was first described
by andy grove
in his book high output management andy
grove was the former
intel ceo he wrote this book very
worthwhile reading he talks about lots
of other topics as well
it is included in the link in the video
description where i talk about my book
recommendations so pick this up
very very big recommendation for me but
there's a chapter in here about
mbo management by objectives which is a
bit of an
old management methodology that was
quite popular several years ago and out
of these ideas the system of okrs has
been developed over time
today okrs are used by many startups but
also larger corporations like google
microsoft twitter
intel and the like now one could make a
full course about what okrs are and how
to implement them but the basic idea is
that you break down your goals into
objectives
so this is the o of okrs but then you
disaggregate every objective into some
key results
some clear measurable key results that
you want to achieve
then together will lead you towards this
objective that you set for yourself as a
goal now we will soon look into a couple
of examples so i did this for myself but
just one other idea i want you to
understand is that the idea is that the
key results that you set for yourself
they should be stretch goals they should
be very ambitious and the idea is that
you should be okay if you achieve 60 to
70 percent of that key result so be bold
had some ambitious targets which might
be achievable
but maybe where you would also be okay
if you maybe only achieve 60 to 70
percent of them after all so now let's
look into a couple of okrs that i
set for myself for the next year as some
of my okrs are quite personal please
understand that i took out some of them
but still i believe that this will give
you a very good insight into the soul
system works let's
jump into it i will not look at my
screen to look into the okrs that i set
for myself so first of all i would like
to encourage you to think about what
might be groups that work for yourself
how you can cluster and aggregate your
goals
personally i have three main areas that
i want to focus on next year first are
some professional goals
second some health and sports goals and
third some other additional personal
growth
goals these might be categories that
work well for you as well or maybe you
also might need to adapt them a little
bit to your needs so let's go into the
professional goals and here i just want
to make it clear that these are not only
my goals related to firm learning i have
some professional goals regarding my
full-time job as well
but due to confidentiality reasons i
don't want to disclose them here in the
video so first of all i have goals for
my three main
channels that i want to focus on next
year and this is youtube instagram and
linkedin what you see here is that i
first of all have the goal on top and
then i have some key results that i want
to achieve
that are supposed to back up this
objective that i write on top so for
youtube it is to become the leading
career and consulting creator on youtube
youtube still is my main channel i'm
still incredibly grateful about the
growth that i experienced
this year and of course i hope that i'd
be able to sustain this over the next
months this way the key activity of
course that i want to continue to do is
to release a quality video every single
week for you guys
and by this i hope that i will be able
to increase my subscriber count over the
next months what you see here now but i
also have for many of my other key
results is that i try to attach
timestamps to them so here not each
quarter i always feel like it's much
more straightforward to disaggregate the
goal
into the quarters so that then each
quarter you can review where you stand
against the goal
and this will also enable you to if
necessary maybe revise or update the
goal throughout the year
instead of realizing that after one or
two quarters you pretty much are
completely off track of the goal and
have no way anymore how to achieve it
now for me to come up with these
specific subscriber goals i looked into
my social blade looked into what they
projected for my channel
of course for me the perspective of
reaching 300 000 subscribers at the end
of next year would be just crazy it
would just be completely insane to me
just the perspective of reaching 100 000
subscribers next year would be an
immense achievement for me and much more
than i would ever have hoped for
so please do not misunderstand this i
will by no means be disappointed if i do
not reach these 300 000 in the end but
again i do want to set a stretch goal
for myself and this is based on my
social blade analytics
similar to that is instagram here my
main objective really is to become more
consistent in the next year by creating
one regular post every week on instagram
i have not been very consistent on
instagram over the last month but i do
want to change and improve this now in
the next year so if you're not following
me on instagram yet my handle is firm
learning i have lots of great content
line up for you on instagram for the
next month so check out my instagram
channel and follow it if you're
interested in these things besides
instagram another channel that is really
important for me for the next year is
linkedin i want to create two regular
posts per week on linkedin next year and
also create one long form article per
month
i do see linkedin as an important
platform for the focus of my firm
learning activities
i do want to put the effort in it that
it's worth and then indeed have the hope
that i will be able to achieve these
follower targets that i'm setting you
for myself the next one is a new topic
though if you're already following me on
my instagram you will already have heard
about it because in the next year i will
release a major new educational offering
for all of you
the working title of this is the analyst
boot camp though i still might change
the title and the idea is that i want to
create a full comprehensive course of
how to be successful
in the first years of your career so
based on the setting of being a young
consultant who joins a team
i will teach you key communication
skills key access skills key powerpoint
skills skills about how to behave in
meetings how you interact with your
leadership with your other colleagues
how you navigate politics and
organizations
many more topics like this this will be
a topic that will go significantly
beyond what you might have already seen
from me on the udemy course i will
probably not host this on udemy but on a
new platform that i will create to be
transparent it will be sold at a higher
price point of the courses that you
already know from me but this is
something where i trust that i will be
able to deliver great value for
everybody who's interested in it so i'm
so excited about releasing this sometime
next year the exact release date is not
defined yet but of course i will keep
you posted here on youtube
if you want to have the latest
information on there please again also
follow me on the instagram so for this
course i hope to complete the base
version at the end of the first quarter
and of course have some objectives in
mind of how many of you will sign up and
then join me in this new offering
next area of goals is my health and
sports related goals and my first
objective here is to get back into
marathon shape so i ran my first
marathon in 2018 and then my second one
in 2019
initially i wanted to do one every year
and i was already signed up for a
marathon in 2020 but then of course it
got cancelled due to the current
situation so if the situation allows i
would love to do a new marathon in 2021
and the main rationale for me is just
that i realized that i just need such a
goal i just need such an event to really
keep me motivated to keep me training if
i do not have such an objective in mind
such a reason why i should train then
it's really hard to motivate myself to
really go out every week and do the
kilometers this is just why it's so
important for me to have such an event
to look forward to and then to train for
so in this world i set myself as a goal
to run a baseline mileage of 100
kilometers per month so this is of
course
not enough to get into a good marathon
shape but this is kind of the minimum
that i want to do every month then in
the first quarter i want to set up a
training plan
and start following it for the marathon
and then hopefully around the third
quarter i will be able to participate in
a marathon
so far in my first two marathons i was
able to always run sub for hours and i
hope to again be able to do that so
honestly i'm not in the perfect form at
the moment
which is why i'm a bit hesitant to now
set myself an even more ambitious goal
so let's try just to get
back and form do a marathon sub for
hours and then this would be fine for me
another goal for me this year for sure
is also to spend more time
outside i also realized over the last
day so i had a bit more time to spend
outside with my family
how great this is how important is this
and it's so easy just to spend the whole
day in front of your desk in front of
your computer but this is just a topic
that is really something that i aspire
to for the upcoming year as well
and in this context my wife who you see
here behind me
actually also made a youtube channel
recently it is called
health and growth and she is talking
about topics like how to stay healthy
how to grow in your life also at work
so if you find this interesting i will
leave a link to her channel below in the
video description
and actually already saw her a couple of
months ago where we made a video
about how you can stay healthy on your
job while working in a high paced career
then the next point is not to try your
new sports i would like to find a new
sport that i can do in parallel to the
running just to mix it up a little bit
and just try to do something completely
else i already tried out a couple of
things over the last years but i didn't
really find something that sticked so
now i have a couple of new ideas for
next year
which one exactly i will pick for next
year also depends a bit on my life
circumstances there are a couple of
things happening currently in my life
where i do not know yet how exactly this
will play out next year once this is
more clear we'll of course inform you on
that but depending on how this goes i
might pick the one or the other sports
and then once this is clear i hope to be
able to come into a routine where then
attend this practice once per week so
the third area are my personal growth
related goals and you have two ones
and the first is to complete my phd
program so not sure if all of you know
but i'm still
working on my phd that i started a
couple of years ago so i started it
during the leave while i still was in
consulting but then i went back to work
and then just hope that i was able to
finish it in parallel to work
this for sure proved a bit more
challenging than i might initially have
thought so i'm still in the process of
completing it but i do hope the next
year i can finish it so i have some
goals related to that
and trust me if i only finish this if i
complete my phd next year
this for me personally will be such a
great success because i'm working it
already for so
long that this alone will make my next
year a great success so thumbs press
guys please cheer for me a little bit
that this works out fine
and then last but not least i always set
for myself a net worth
target then i break down by quarter so
if you've already watched some of my
other personal finance related videos
for instance how i achieved the 50
savings rate or my general strategy on
investments you already know that this
is a topic that is very important to me
and since i started to systematically
track my net worth a couple of years ago
i feel like this alone has helped me to
really increase it and really just focus
on it and making sure that this number
goes up over time so if you've never
heard about this what the net worth
means is pretty much just the difference
of the value of your assets so for
instance your stock portfolio some other
investments that you might have or
anything else of significant value that
you own
subtracted by all the liabilities that
you have on your name so if you still
have student loans or some other debt or
maybe a mortgage on your house you would
deduct that from the value of your
assets to end up with your net worth so
i have a more complex spreadsheet that i
use to track my own net worth so if
you're interested to see how this looks
like
write me a comment below in the comment
section and then i might make a whole
video just to show you how exactly i
tracked my net worth but independent of
that i believe this is just really one
of the best things that you should do in
my opinion everybody should do this
it gives you clarity and focus and also
just helps you to make sure that all the
money that you earn
you don't just spend it and consume it
but that you invested and that you do
make sure that it goes towards
increasing your net worth
so i hope you found these tips helpful
as always if you have any question at
all leave me a comment below in the
comment section
and i will make sure to answer every
single comment that you write
and of course as you know if you write a
comment this also helps me with the
youtube systems
so every comment is very much
appreciated if you took
any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on all my content
i release one video every single
saturday
now what i would like to hear from you
is what are your goals for 2021
let me know below in the comments as
well i'd love to hear about your
aspirations
what you desire to do and you desire to
achieve in the next year
if you want to see even more from me
also follow me on my instagram my handle
is firm learning
also have a mating list there's a sign
up link to that below in the video
description
and also feel free to follow and reach
out on linkedin
again you can find a link below in the
video description
now i want to say thank you to all the
members of firm learning you are helping
the cause of this
channel tremendously if you want to know
how to become a member as well just hit
the join button next to the subscribe
button to learn
what it's all about and yes there are
some member
only perks that you will get as a member
so if you're watching until now thank
you so much
next video we release next saturday see
you again soon
goodbye this is heinek from firm
learning